Four Yemenis young and old a ceasefire can't come soon enough
As many as 18 million people more than half the country are close to starvation
Four years of conflict have brought Yemen to its knees
We have no shelter. We have nothing. We don't even have water our children are sick
Doctors just can't keep up with the number of malnourished patients
We receive 25 malnutrition cases every single week our capacity here is very limited
Renewed fighting flared up in the port city of heard a day late Monday
But the UN is pushing ahead with its efforts to broker peace talks between the warring parties
The Yemeni government has said it would send a delegation to talks
And that came after Houthi rebels said they'd stop missile attacks on Saudi Arabia the Yemeni government's major backer
But as ever in this conflict
skepticism remains
This is just a way for the saudi-led coalition to establish an excuse for themselves and abandon their obligations
the Coalition will not stop the aggression the
Aggressors do not usually stop and they see these sorts of ceasefire agreements as a sign of weakness
The UN hopes these suspicions are proved wrong and that fighting around the key battleground of her data is soon stopped for good
beyond that Yemen needs a long-term plan for peace and
Even with all sides at the table, that will be a major challenge
We're joined now by Tamara Karolos from the charity Save the Children in sana in Yemen Tamara
Thank you so much for joining us here on TWU as we said there is fresh fighting in ho data
This is a very important port city. What does this mean for the millions of Yemenis who are reliant on food aid
Well, it is a very dangerous situation, of course, this is the third escalation
Since July the city now is almost encircled. There's only one named out
And obviously the port supplies 80% of the supplies for Yemen including obviously
Much-needed food aid and fuel but also commercial food and fuel as well. Um, but it's not just about that
I mean, I guess the situation right now in the city is also quite dire
There had been a lull for the last few days but fighting
Resumed last last item this morning. We've heard from our staff. There's no air strikes. We've seen hospitals destroyed
We've seen a large number of civilian
Casualties both dead and injured especially with children in the last 10 15 days
We have to support about 15 children that have been injured because of shrapnel or bullets
And even yesterday we heard that some of the suppliers of food in the city had pulled out a stocks for fear of fighting
Which which creates a new?
Situation for about three hundred thousand people still trapped in the city tell me we are hearing that more Aid is coming
It's been reported that Saudi Arabia and the United Arab Emirates will contribute around 500 million dollars in a new aid program for Yemen
But will that make a difference if the fighting can't be stopped?
No, I think this is the the critical issue on the figures
We're working on right now in terms of eight and a half million people who are extremely food insecure meaning
They don't know where their next meal is coming from they are reliant on Aid but again figures coming out
Closer to the end of this month. I will show that the numbers increase by millions
I think at one point it's not just about the money, but obviously about stopping the
Conflict, but it's also about our capacity to respond
And I think if we reach a tipping point where many more million Yemenis are food insecure
or perhaps even pushed to be on the brink of famine and
It'll be very difficult for us to be able to respond and to just roll that back
Tamara on the diplomatic front
Just briefly if you can the UN Security Council is going to discuss a draft resolution later today
How hopeful are you that we're gonna see an end to the fighting
Well, it's rather than being hopeful
It's more of hoping I guess the issue again that there is no viable solution to to this conflict except through peaceful negotiations
the alternative is
Catastrophic this is the world's worst
humanitarian crisis and if the fighting continues not just around her data, but elsewhere in the country we could see that
situation get
even worse
Tamir Karolos from Save the Children in Sanaa. Thank you so much for joining us